Fox news is a completely toxic extremist,
right wing echo chamber, mostly sympathetic
to president Donald Trump, but occasionally
not.
But every once in a while one of their anchors,
Shepard Smith would tell the truth.
He would say what Donald Trump says in this
video, what Donald Trump said in this press
conference is not true.
He would say, what the Trump administration
is telling you is without evidence, and we
knew that Shep was out of place this entire
time, but we also recognized it might've been
useful to Fox news to have him there, to provide
ideological cover to allow themselves to say
marginally more credibly.
We are fair and balanced.
There is diversity of opinion on our network.
And recently it started getting very publicly
ugly.
For example, Shep Smith, a week or two ago,
interviewed Fox legal analyst, Andrew Nepal,
Caetano, a former judge and Nepal Caetano
said, listen, Trump's actions with Ukraine
are both impeachable and potentially criminal.
Fellow Fox news host, Tucker Carlson came
in and attacked the judge and then Shep and
Tucker got into a public argument that had
to be mediated by Fox news.
Higher ups telling Shep Smith, you've got
to it out.
That was a big signal that things were not
looking good for Shep Smith and Shep Smith
has now quit Fox news.
Here's a little bit of him signing off on
his last broadcast.
I've worked with the most talented, dedicated
and focused professionals I've ever known.
They sacrifice endlessly and tirelessly to
get the news exactly right and I am so proud
of them and I'm honored to have anchored their
work each day.
I'll miss them and our time together greatly
and deeply.
So recently I asked the company to allow me
to leave Fox news after requesting that I
stay, they obliged under our agreement.
I won't be reporting elsewhere, at least in
the near future, but I will be able to see
more of geo and Luchea and our friends and
family.
Then we'll see what comes along.
This is my last newscast here.
Thank you for watching today and over the
decades as I traveled to many of your communities
and anchored this program, studio B and Fox
report plus endless marathon hours of breaking
news.
It's been an honor.
So as Shep says, they're contractually, he's
not allowed to pop up on CNN or MSNBC or ABC
news for some time.
Who knows what he'll be doing financially?
He's just fine.
He doesn't have to work probably ever again
if he doesn't want to.
But let's go through this sequentially.
First of all, Shep says it was voluntary.
I believe that strictly speaking, it was voluntary,
but it was voluntary in a context where his
boss has had recently come to him and said,
do not go after Tucker Carlson.
Again, it was happening as president Trump
was increasingly attacking Shepard Smith.
It was coming in this context of increased
tension with the broader network because of
his criticisms of Donald Trump and it's pretty
clear that other Fox hosts, we're not expecting
this.
Based on what they said on air, there was
speculation that Shep was pushed out by Trump's
attorney general William Barr.
Now you might say William Barr.
What on earth is William Barr have to do with
this?
Well, it turns out that the day before Shep's
resignation, William Barr met with a Fox news,
a owner, a news corporation owner, a Rupert
Murdoch.
It is sketchy, but there is no evidence right
now that the meeting was directly related
to Shep Smith.
So then we get to, is this good or bad?
Because all along I've been saying on the
one hand, Shep telling the truth every once
in awhile might Pierce the echo chamber filter
bubble of the Fox audience and that's a good
thing.
But on the other hand, having at Fox news,
as I mentioned already, gives them some plausible
deniability about being anything other than
tools of the American right wing.
I think in the net, the benefits of shepherd
Fox did not outweigh the ideological cover
that he was providing to them.
And especially after becoming a target of
Donald Trump.
Uh, I, I, I understand his decision to do
this whenever he is allowed contractually
to get back on the air somewhere else, he
is going to be in a great position to advance
his career.
Not that that's my primary concern.
I'm guessing he's not going to make as boneheaded
decisions as the ones that Megan Kelly made
when she left Fox news, which basically imploded
her career.
That remains to be seen.
But there are still lots of Fox viewers who
see this as an unabashed victory.
They hated Shep.
They would, anytime he told the truth, start
making homophobic comments about Shep as if
his sexual orientation has anything to do
with whether he's telling us the truth or
not.
They see him leaving as a victory.
And in a sense for them it may be because
the Fox viewers that are beyond reach, the
ones that are beyond the hope of being pulled
back into considering the reality of the facts
on the ground, they saw Shap as a threat quite
frankly.
And for them Shep leaving is indeed a victory.
So not surprising probably in the net.
Uh, something that is not going to have any
kind of real impact on the 2020 election or
on Donald Trump, but not a surprising thing.
As we've been following for a couple of years
now and we will see where Shep lands and we
will see.
Interestingly also, will there be any, you
know, Trump has also been going after Chris
Wallace who less frequently than Shep, but
every once in awhile we'll insert some truth
into his broadcasts or his challenging questions
to Trump officials.
Is Chris Wallace the next target?
If you look at Trump's Twitter over the last
couple of days, you see that the answer is
probably yes.
Chris Wallace is the next target.